[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
manga has transitioned
into magaga
magaga
oh this is gonna go over
like a wet fart in a white thong it
definitely is not gonna be good for
Donald Trump nor the Republicans last
night's
um Rally or announcement whatever the
[ __ ] it was it was the same old [ __ ]
same [ __ ] speech he's been given for
months
nothing new he obviously did not have a
time for a rewrite after the Republicans
absolutely got crushed in the midterms
with their messaging and their narrative
that didn't get anywhere any traction
they barely they are barely going to
take the house if they take the house
they can't even decide who the [ __ ]
speaker of the house is going to be
they have no coalition
of any coherency at this point
uh Mitch McConnell is going to be
challenged by
um Rick Scott of Florida the guy who
[ __ ] failed
to get them the Senate and not only did
he fail to get them the Senate it looks
like Herschel Walker is going to get
[ __ ] trounced in Georgia in a runoff
which is only going to give Democrats
more seats in the Senate
and Donald Trump thinks it's a good time
to announce and run I told you yesterday
I hope he does and I'm so excited that
he did and it didn't it didn't he did
not fail he did not fail here
to start off his losing campaign on the
wrong foot
so much so that there's video of him
rambling on
as he does continuing to talk and talk
and talk and talk about the same old
[ __ ] nonsense
and people are trying to get out of the
room and they won't let him leave they
lock the [ __ ] doors
because they don't want the room to
empty out while he's talking they don't
want that imagery
and that's basically trumpism at this
point guys [ __ ] nuts even Ivanka
Trump won't even support him in 2024.
she put out a [ __ ] statement I'm not
I'm not I'm not participating in this
she must be worried about her own
indictments
and that's that's the thing here because
I want to talk about that today because
a lot of people are saying that he's
doing this this to fend off indictments
that's not what he's doing
I'm going to explain it why he's not
trying to fend off indictments
but this speech last night
was every single [ __ ] talking point
of their strategy to win in the midterm
that lost
every [ __ ] one you go right down the
list
this morning his sick of ants can't stop
talking about gas prices again this
morning
the Republican party is begging begging
for someone to be a leader
and this guy thinks he's going to run
again
and he's going to win again he may win
the primary I I think that's part of his
strategy here if you want to know the
honest truth I'm going to explain it
here in the next several minutes
of what what I think he's trying to do
because everyone keeps saying he's
trying to fend off indictments that's
not what he's trying to do he is far
beyond trying to fend off indictments
it's not even close
but I told you I wanted him to run
because he's going to destroy the
Republican party and it's already
happening before your eyes Ron DeSantis
this morning lashing out
lashing out at reporters
because the Cheeto dusk q and honor
decides to [ __ ] announce he's gonna
run for the next election before we even
know the results of this one
the Republic the Republican party is
[ __ ] pissed at him
and there's a mounting Insurgency inside
their party the junkins the DeSantis I
mean he's already pissed off the turtle
in the Senate
and Mitch McConnell is gonna be the
minority leader he's gonna be the leader
Rick Scott is not going to mount any
kind of campaign against this
[ __ ]
I told you for weeks that Mitch
McConnell was the happiest guy in
Washington
that Trump is going to lose these Senate
races Mitch McConnell is okay
with being the minority leader of the
senate for now
if it means in the future he can be the
majority leader
if Trump would have got his way and won
these seats Mitch McConnell it is
obvious now that Donald Trump would have
made sure that all the Senators that he
got elected and the ones loyal to him
would would absolutely cancel Mitch
McConnell as the leader
Mitch McConnell knew that and there's
only one thing that matters to Mitch
McConnell most is his power
Ron DeSantis is the same [ __ ] way
that weak piece of [ __ ] Ron DeSantis oh
my God for them to think that this guy
is going to be a national ticket winner
you are you're a bunch of dumb
[ __ ] I cannot wait for Ron
DeSantis and Donald Trump to fight it
out on the trail oh my God this is going
to be beautiful
Donald Trump is gonna absolutely chew up
and spit out Ron DeSantis on the [ __ ]
floor
and there's part of the the Maga
movement not the magaga the magaga is
now full on Trump right because you got
Maga which is you know white Christian
nationalism Incorporated and then you
have magaga which is now the Trump wing
of
Maga white white Christian nationalists
Incorporated you know the America First
Nazi party right
now we have magaga
I'm not [ __ ] you these are I'm not
making this [ __ ] up they're doing it
I'm just [ __ ] telling you what the
hell's going on
but here is here is what Donald Trump's
plan is okay and you really have to
think about the timing of indictments
and trials
and you can you can easily go back and
look at January 6 and use it kind of as
a template here right right now um we
have like the old Keepers trials going
on right now we're gonna have the proud
boys trial here soon in the next few
months
and that's two years after the event
okay so two years after the event
this last summer
is when the doj and the FBI and the
federal judge issued a search warrant
for Mar-A-Lago for those documents
and they used three
three statutes
to go get those documents to issue that
search warrant
now that was the summer right
okay you found one he's going to be
indicted on those charges now we pretty
much
it it is looking like he it's just a
matter of how many charges that they're
going to mount against him that they're
going to get a grand jury to to put
against him
that's probably the first indictment
that's going to drop on him unless
weisselberg
keeps throwing him under the bus and New
York decides to charge him or they just
decide to refer him to the southern
district of New York for the crimes that
Alan weisselberg is testifying in court
too I don't know if you've been paying
attention to that hey fake Gabe are you
out there there's a criminal trial going
on New York and Alan weiselberg the CFO
of trump org is turning on Donald Trump
I told you there was a criminal trial
dummy okay and Just Gotta Throw That
Into Me here's the thing
Donald Trump is timing this in a way
that when he gets indicted probably
January February March is probably when
we're looking at these indictments
coming from these grand juries there's a
lot of [ __ ] to go through I mean there's
[ __ ] thousands of documents that this
guy stole so they have to really figure
out what charges and how many
he's going to have a pile of charges
against him
now if these charges come down in the
first quarter of next year
he's not going to go to trial then and
really Donald Trump will be able to
delay his trial until sometime the
summer of 2024.
okay you follow so far we got
indictments next year for the documents
probably other indictments and other
jurisdictions and more superseding
indictments in other jurisdictions
possibly indictments in States
but the trial for the documents case
will be the first one more than likely
that Donald Trump will face and the
reason why is because it's pretty much
just him on this indictment the January
6 uh State elector scheme there's going
to be a whole conspiracy right it's
going to be a whole conspiracy of people
there's going to be dozens of people
indicted in that case
documents case cut and dry guys stole
this [ __ ] [ __ ] he lied he obstructed
it's it's cut and dry
so that trial is likely to be first
his first federal trial now
if the trial is kicked down the road
until 2024 this guy can say hey I'm a
legitimate candidate
for president of the United States I
can't go to trial so he is not trying to
fend off indictments folks he knows
indictments are coming
he committed crime they he knows they
know he committed crime he knows the
crime he committed they know the crime
he's committed they know he's obstructed
in the investigation of those crimes
he's [ __ ]
and not only is he [ __ ] in the
documents case he seems to be really
[ __ ]
uh Alan weiselberg's really uh digging
in there
and and the reason why is because Alan
weissenberg doesn't want to go to Rikers
for years on end
he'd rather just spend months there
so Donald Trump is not running to fend
off indictments folks
he knows he's getting indicted he is
running to fend off a trial is what he's
going to do
now this is all a losing battle in the
first place and the reason why is
because of you
it's the people
we did the work that we needed to do in
democracy to make sure to save it and
here's the biggest
the the biggest tell last night he
absolutely did not attack those losing
candidates
he mentioned Herschel Walker which is a
[ __ ] a
death row Herschel Walker is done
Herschel Walker is done
as far as I'm concerned now we have to
lean into that we have to make sure that
race comes out the way we want because
we want to have more subpoena power in
the Senate that's going to be very
important folks
and it's going to be very important just
to Ram judges down their [ __ ] throats
on the federal bench for two years just
[ __ ] cram them down their throats
[ __ ] them
that's gonna be all important
but he did not go after his opponents in
the race he did not go after the people
who lost
that is very [ __ ] important
because he is terrified terrified of
running against people in the party
he knows that there's an Insurgency
inside the Republican party that is
ready to [ __ ] trash him and get rid
of him and throw him in the garbage
he knows it
that's why he's running now he can't
wait for this to build against him
he has to try to build some sort of
[ __ ]
some sort of mass of people that's going
to vote for him in primaries so that way
when he gets down to going to trial in
2024 he can use the excuse that he's got
a legitimate presidential campaign that
he's running and they can't take him to
trial that may work I don't know depends
on the judge
that's what he's doing
that's clearly what he's doing
I mean you can doubt me good luck
but that's what he's doing
Donald Trump is going to be indicted he
knows it his allies know it his
attorneys know it
the doj knows it
he's in big trouble with the documents
case and he's even in bigger trouble
probably in the state of New York
because this James has already referred
a lot of the Civil civil civil case
it's a different case in the criminal
case but she's referred that to the sdny
which I would I would imagine that the
sdny is paying attention Alan
weisselberg's testimony in open court
under oath
basically saying that yeah you goddamn
right Donald Trump had everything to do
with this tax fraud says [ __ ] ID he
was in the room we were talking about it
guy is never not in the room when you're
talking about fraud it's his favorite
thing to do
so this idea
that this [ __ ] three-time loser isn't
going to be a four-time loser
is is absolute batshit crazy that these
people think that this guy's gonna win
he's not gonna win he won't win he
probably won't even win one primary
he probably won't even win one primary
but as long as he has his lackeys
funneling him money he can pretend to
run for president up until the trial
Donald Trump never has the end in sight
if you really think Donald Trump's
running around like oh this is my number
one goal this is my goal and I will read
that's not what he does
if you've ever listened to him speak
about health care or infrastructure uh
two weeks to just give it two weeks two
weeks two weeks two weeks not two weeks
in two weeks and two weeks he never has
an end goal there is never one with this
[ __ ] chucklehead ever
he never has the end in sight
all he's doing is stalling that is it he
is stalling to position himself where he
can make up another lie
that's it that's all he's doing and he's
stalling the trial he's not stalling in
diamonds he's [ __ ]
and you just lay out the timetable the
timeline of how that would all work and
you see it it's clear as day
it's clear as day now I'm gonna be the
probably the first one to say this
into a microphone
and I probably won't get credit fine
whatever you take this and go say it out
loud everywhere
go say it out loud
type it in on Twitter you don't just go
go now not well not now
settle down but when you're talking to
people
when you're conversating with people
his strategy here is to fend off a trial
because it doesn't matter about
indictments you can get indicted all
[ __ ] day long indictment after
indictment after indictment after
indictment
a trial or a plea deal is what sends you
to prison trust me
and this [ __ ] does not want to
go to trial
he does not want to go to trial
best case scenario is either he wins
which is not a scenario at all or
republican wins to Pardon him
and he begs for the part
that's best case scenarios
but he's trying to stall
the trial the documents trial really I
mean there's going to be other trials
he's likely going to have to serve in a
trial
um possibly in the southern district of
New York for the crimes that he's
committed with the Trump organization
the tax fraud
um if Alan weiselberg is telling the
truth which it's he is under oath and
this judge is uh
told him you [ __ ] tell the truth or
you're going to Rikers for a long time
[ __ ]
so um rather the sdny moves on charges
again this case is in the Manhattan DA's
office this is the Manhattan D.A trying
this criminal case against the Trump
organization it's Criminal
and weissenberg has already pled to
crimes
and now he's giving the goods for Donald
Trump
for those same crimes
so we'll see if the sdny moves on that
case now we also have the [ __ ]
the the election case in Georgia that
Fannie Willis is moving forward on more
news on that Michael Flynn now has to
testify to the grand jury
um which is big they said no you're
gonna have to testify uh Brian Kemp who
is no [ __ ] cheerleader for Donald
Trump
the Brian Kemp arm of the party Brian
Kemp DeSantis youngkin these governors
these Governors are turning on him folks
and that's a big deal
that's a really big deal
it's huge imagine imagine a Republican
primary in Florida where two floor two
men from Florida
are in the primary and one of them holds
office and the other one doesn't and the
other one won his election and the other
one didn't
it's not going to go well it's not gonna
look
it's not going to give a great
appearance
for mounting a winning campaign in the
Republican Party
this is all great for us by the way you
should be absolutely ecstatic about the
absolute [ __ ] Fallout inside the
Republican Party
you should be ecstatic about it because
there's even a chance here
I'm not even paying attention if the
Democrats lose the house which it looks
like they could buy a seed or two
they can still win I don't think the
votes are in their favor the counts
aren't really in their favor but it's
possibility we're gonna find out
probably sometime later this week or
over the weekend what the what the
actual result of some of these races are
that we're waiting on and when there was
a few more called this morning I believe
here's the thing
Kevin McCarthy can't get to 18.
and there's Insurgency inside the house
Republican caucus that is going to make
sure he's not going to get 218.
now if the Democrats end up with two
17-16
they really only need four or five
Republicans
to get someone I don't know maybe Liz
Cheney now this would be
um this would be
hell a very interesting time in history
where the entire Democratic caucus
decides that you know what
a Liz Cheney type
Republican is better as Speaker of the
House than one of these other
chuckleheads
if the goal is to absolutely smash
fascism in this country
and by bearing trumpism you're gonna do
that
and there's no person ready ready to
bury trumpism than Liz Cheney
and Liz Chaney knows the [ __ ] house
she was in Republican leadership
she likely would be a better speaker in
the first place than Kevin McCarthy
because he's a [ __ ] bonehead
and I I mean for the Republicans she
could be a better speaker like she could
get more [ __ ] done if
if she was their [ __ ] leader because
Kevin McCarthy's dumb [ __ ]
but we'll set that aside for a second
imagine if the Democratic caucus
could come up with enough strategy
to make sure that on the floor Liz
Cheney gets enough votes from them and a
handful of Republicans to become the
speaker of the house that is a that's a
real [ __ ] thing that could happen
I think it's you know far-fetched
because I don't see a lot of um
Democrats casting a ballot
for Liz Cheney but
you know democracy is on the line here
democracy is on the line and there is
not one [ __ ] thing that Liz Cheney
not one Q Anon thing that Liz Cheney is
going to let in these committees
or on the floor you have to remember
that the Speaker of the House controls
the [ __ ] committees and controls the
floor
that's the most important thing and they
are [ __ ] just
foaming at the mouth to talk about a
laptop for two [ __ ] years laptop this
laptop that Hunter Biden this Hunter
Biden's the president
all kinds of weird crazy [ __ ] they're
gonna talk about it's gonna be full on Q
and on inside these these committees
100 full stop Q Anon
if Kevin McCarthy or or Andy Biggs Jesus
[ __ ] Christ
is the Speaker of the House
so I don't know maybe the Democrats
decide that that's a good idea hmm I
don't know could be a strategy to save
democracy now what do you think
I think it's again it's a little
far-fetched
but I don't know
there's word that the Republicans are
trying to get Democrats to flip seats
Kevin McCarthy is is looking for
Democrats to come to the Republican
Party
so that way he can outmaneuver these I
don't know there's five or six of these
[ __ ] chuckleheads he convinced
Marjorie Taylor green that it was not in
the best interest
especially her best interest to go
against him he commenced her of that
which is you know maybe she's smarter
than I gave her credit for
because really in the grand scheme of
things
this threat of some sort of moderate
non-trump speaker
threatens the entire reason they wanted
the house in the first place
which is to kill the January 6th Select
Committee
and to talk about Hunter Biden's laptop
from now until Kingdom Come
and they're probably they'll probably do
uh viewings in some of these Committees
of that movie two thousand mules I'm
sure
I don't know I'm just just snowballing
here I mean think of the craziest
[ __ ] Cuban on [ __ ] you can think of
and that's what we're gonna see
and these Republican house committee um
meetings if if someone like Kevin
McCarthy or Annie Biggs is a speaker
we have we have crazy times ahead of us
folks there are crazy times ahead of us
and there is no telling what turns may
come in our democracy the good news is
that in these states Pennsylvania
Michigan Wisconsin and Arizona you did
your job
you went out and you made sure that in
those swing states that Q an honors
election deniers had no power that's the
most important thing
I know 2024 is going to be crazy I know
it's gonna be a fight and we've already
started this stupid conversation
but I told you this would happen as soon
as 2020 I figured it would you know
barely at least have this [ __ ] counted
first
but I knew as soon as 2022 was counted
that 2024 was going to be right on the
plate because right now 2022 however it
falls we did what we needed to do to
make sure democracy still has strength
and is still part of the fabric of this
country
now our job for the next two years is to
work our [ __ ] asses off
for the next two years to make sure we
keep what we did in 2022 it is most
important
and we have a lot of wind in our backs
folks
we have a lot of wind at our backs
there's going to be more gin voter gen Z
voters than ever before and they are
engaged and we should engage with them
we should engage with them about
democracy that generation is more
interested in how our democracy Works
than we've had in a long time way more
interested than my generation than
Millennials way more interested in how
democracy works
and it's encouraging it's encouraging
that they are a pro-democracy generation
it's very encouraging and I think it's
only going to get better as we go along
2024 is a long way off folks and the
demographics are going to continue to
change over the next two years and it's
not going to change in the favor of
fascism or authoritarianism it's not
that's why they were so hell-bent on
lies
and they're still outbound on lies to
convince people to vote for them because
they have no good ideas besides
authoritarianism
and that's not going to win them
elections
but we're going to keep talking we're
going to keep yelling into this
microphone for two full hours every
single weekday we're gonna fight for our
democracy we're gonna keep leaning in we
cannot let down
we can't stop now is the time to focus
on 2024 and lean into that election I
know we're 720 some [ __ ] days but
that's all we got
to make sure the work what we did in
2022 doesn't go to waste it's super
important for you for me your families
your children your community
even the mcgaggers out there the magagas
they won't know it but they should thank
us
I'm serious it's magaga it went from
Maga to magaga they have gag gag in
their
I don't know how they're gonna see it
but that's how I'm gonna say it [ __ ]
them magaga
it makes you want to [ __ ] gag
everyone thank you for joining us you
are the best audience in the entire
world in the entire world I want to tell
you something
um give MJ in the chat a thank you she's
having trouble with her chat and MJ is
one of the best my she is the best
moderator in the world we also have
Margie and Robin but MJ's been having a
little issue so stick with her there be
kind
um she's we're trying to get some issues
figured out uh MJ we love you everyone
loves you stay everyone
um give MJ some love in the chat she
she's been frustrated the last couple
days we've been trying to fix a problem
it's a technical thing and we just we
can't figure it out but we'll get there
we'll get there we love you MJ everybody
come every single weekday two full hours
noon Eastern 11 Central nine Pacific
here on YouTube Twitter and twitch make
sure to get into the chat on YouTube
just subscribe to the channel we're so
close to twelve thousand if we're not
over it already
you guys are you guys are piling on the
audience is getting bigger and bigger
and we're we're expanding
we're expanding because you guys are
watching like crazy on Facebook
thousands of people watch on Facebook
and you know we simulcast from the Midas
touch Facebook page but you can also
follow our page at the Tony Michaels we
broadcast there as well and there's more
and more downloads every single day on
Apple Spotify Google your favorite
directories make sure to leave us a
great review why you're at your favorite
directory subscribing to the show also
we have more people now than ever on
Twitch
it's just growing and growing and
growing
this whole pro-democracy thing is
working and we run off your support here
at the Tony Michaels podcast so if you'd
like to support us monetarily that would
be great you don't have to but that
would be great go to Tony michaels.live
That's Tony Michaels dot live you can
leave a one-time tip or you can set it
up to to take it out each month if you
if that's what you choose to do any
amount we we would encourage any amount
and we appreciate your support because
we run on it so go to the tip jar at
Tony Michaels dot live and leave us a
tip if we're doing the work of democracy
that you love
but more than anything hell go to the
merch store this shirt this shirt design
is going to become more and more
relevant as we go along here
Ron DeSantis can go [ __ ] himself you can
get a hoodie in this thing as well but
Ron DeSantis can go [ __ ] himself as a
great design everyone loves it go to
store.dtonymichaels.com that's
store.thetonymichaels.com I've got a
coffee mug with it on it and it looks
beautiful
oh it looks beautiful and the coffee
seems to taste a lot better in a Ron
DeSantis can go [ __ ] himself mug so go
to
store.thetonymichaels.com check out the
Rhonda Santos can go [ __ ] himself merch
everyone stick around we're gonna be
back right after these messages we have
a ton of video to go through
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[Music]
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show thanks
for sticking around through the break
boy do we have a lot of video to show
you
um I'm just gonna show you a bunch of
video from the Cheeto desk you and
honors little announcement whatever the
[ __ ] it was last night and really it
really was like a wet fart in a white
thong like I said earlier
um and people were trying to leave the
room that's one of the videos I want to
show you a people like scurring out and
they wouldn't let them [ __ ] leave
because they didn't want that room in
thing
you're like hell no that'll be bad bad
imagery uh Jonathan Carl even uh was
talking live as people were trying to
exit the room so I want to show you a
couple of those videos
I want to show you the part my most my
my favorite moment of the entire because
I watched I don't know I watched about
35 minutes of it I tortured myself for
about 35 minutes watching this game
[ __ ] just Yak on about the same [ __ ]
he's been talking about for the last six
years and the same stupid [ __ ]
talking points that they lost on in this
[ __ ] midterm
I I had to turn it off eventually it was
just so [ __ ] pathetic hey this is
[ __ ] pathetic
but there was one moment
where dude thought
dude thought he'd been president for
decades I'm not [ __ ] you I'm not
exactly sure like how it got written
into the speech or if he was reading it
or if he was
off the cuff I have no [ __ ] idea I
have no idea what this [ __ ] was
talking about but he
and I'm going to show you he's talking
about how
he had he he had he while he was
President there was decades without War
it's really [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] but
the videos I want to show you this
morning more than anything are some of
these videos from these reactions of
this thing
because it is mixed folks it is really
mixed
of this guy's announcement they did not
want him to do this
it is even even his sycophants even the
people out there supporting him and
talking about how great he is and how
he's going to win again and all this
[ __ ]
even they you can tell did not want him
to [ __ ] do this they don't eat they
don't even know who has the house yet
and what seats are going to be
seats they have no [ __ ] clue yet they
just don't know
and he's already announcing this is
[ __ ] a weird ass time that we live in
it's weird folks it's a weird it's a
weird [ __ ] timeline we're in
and it's just a q Anon world and we're
living in it oh here here you go here
you go
there you go here's fake game he says
this guy is so happy Trump is running so
he doesn't have to talk about failing
Democrat policies
fake game
you guys ran on quote unquote what your
the failing Democrat policies were my
friend you know bathrooms gas prices
inflation and you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
lost you [ __ ] lost man you lost a
seat in the Senate
you're you damn near you damn near are
gonna lose the house one [ __ ]
sneeze one [ __ ] sneeze of
Republicans flopping parties here or one
[ __ ] Liz Cheney being the speaker of
the house and you guys lost it that's it
you're done
you're done my friend
I don't I don't know if you know this
but you guys talked about the failing
quote unquote Democrat policies
for the last two years from the moment
Brandon took office
and you guys failed at taking advantage
of the failing Democrat policies my
friend
so I I love that you're here
every day just puking up your nonsense
in your Trump copy machine into the chat
and I knew I knew going into today that
you would be deflated I understand that
and the reason why you would be deflated
is because Donald Trump's announcement
wasn't that he was gonna go to
Washington and rip Joe Biden at the
White House and he's now the president I
understand that did you guys notice this
the Q and honors on Facebook Reddit all
these [ __ ] weird ass channels all
these weird places the Q and honors like
fake Gabe here the Q and honors we're
out there going what the [ __ ] they were
pissed off
they were mad that he was announcing
he's running for 2024.
they were pissed off not that he's
running they're mad that they were lied
to they were [ __ ] lied to they really
believed he was the The Shadow president
and it was the military and Joe Biden
was on a set in Hollywood and I don't
know he was being a puppet or some [ __ ]
I don't know what the [ __ ] they thought
all kinds of crazy ass [ __ ] crazy ass
Ivermectin horse Pace type [ __ ]
and they're really disappointed
apparently on the internet that this guy
didn't Ascend to the presidency
yesterday that's what they thought they
thought the big announcement was Him
Gonna Be president
apparently I don't know maybe fake gate
can clear this up for us what do you
think fake Gabe are you disappointed
that he wouldn't he didn't declare
himself King
and I'll fake gay poor guy poor guy we
like having him here though I know he's
he's gonna have a really rough time over
the next few years it's gonna get worse
and worse and worse because this idea
last night also that Trump was saying
that um he alluded to the fact that the
reason why the 2022 midterm didn't go
the way that it should have gone
was because people just didn't suffer
enough
let's pretty much I mean within a you
know
he had a different way of putting it
but here's the thing
he said it's gonna where it's gonna get
even worse it's gonna get even worse uh
here see look here see I told you I told
you fake HQ went on fake gay man get
some [ __ ] help man there's I mean I
know this country is horrible at mental
health care
and really we're we as we as liberals
are trying to work hard to make sure
that you have access to mental health
care I mean I want all people especially
you [ __ ] mind [ __ ] delusional q and
honors to have access to mental health
care I believe that is a huge problem in
this country we need to seek mental
health care for you people quick
he says Biden does have a fake Oval
Office whoosh dude holy [ __ ] I'm sure
you're gonna post a link too somewhere
[Music]
did your Uncle Earl type that in on
Facebook oh man
oh buddy well buddy I don't know if you
know this fake Gabe or not
I don't know if you know this
but that little show that you're [ __ ]
Mussolini your mango Mussolini used to
have you remember that show called The
Apprentice do you remember
they actually built a fake conference
room
like literally your guy pretends to be
president while he was in the office and
even after he he has a fake presidential
seal my dude
oh my God they gave you never disappoint
that's why I love having you here I
don't know if you got banned on the
minus Dutch Facebook page but we loving
love having you here on our Facebook
page because you never disappoint my
friend Gabe Sanchez fake gabier says
that Biden has a fake Oval Office it's
incredible this guy I uh like uh like at
the George Soros Studio or it's kind of
like your place over there you know all
that stuff behind us yes right if you
chose a background on a green screen it
would definitely be that it would be for
sure this I don't know I don't know
about you I mean this makes me feel
right more real more real oh like a
human you know like I feel like a human
so not a cyborg really yeah or an
Android but a human a human fake gabier
though believes that Joe Biden has a
holy [ __ ] that's why we love having you
they gave me never disappoint like you
you you never you never disappoint in
the chat and I I'm really sad that maybe
you got banned from minus touch Facebook
let me tell you something as long as you
don't say some crazy [ __ ] and I you know
what I mean by that a racist [ __ ] or
start attacking people I'm Gonna Leave
You on my Facebook page because what the
hell would we do with that your crazy
ass well I mean we know online fake Gabe
is the baddest toughest oh he is most
[ __ ]
bad guy on the planet right like nobody
is more [ __ ] no one's got the fake no
one's got the more of the fake fake
links like fake Gabe I don't know but
seriously fake Gabe I gotta give that
guy credit or
whatever game faking is
but I want to say this
that guy really comes into the chat
[ __ ] like he's been roiding out all
morning he just did a [ __ ] power 20
set on the [ __ ] bench press he's like
oh where's my [ __ ] eggs and my
protein shake oh man I think he does
pull-ups like Marjorie Taylor green
those weird [ __ ] pull-ups I think
that fake Gabe in his mind right has a
whole workout Montage that is akin to
something you would see like a 1980s
film with like Sylvester Stallone or
like Jean-Claude Van Damme or Arnold
Schwarzenegger
baby exactly where he's like I'll be
back and if he believes that those are
documentaries I mean he believes I think
maybe I think you know and sometimes
maybe fake a really is in the fields and
he has like a Footloose dancing moment
in a warehouse with a bunch of chains
doing flips and Gymnastic moments I
think fake game has many of these
moments where he really does believe
that he is the alpha he's like a Nick
Adams if anyone doesn't know who Nick
Adams is go to Twitter and look up Nick
Adams and you will understand proclaimed
dude if you're if you're an alpha male
if you're now if you really are an alpha
male if that's right I invited you on
the show yeah man come on I literally
said come on what's your email [ __ ] yeah
we will put you on camera like a
[ __ ] listen send this send us a
DM or send us a message send us send
your so you can you can make a fake
email right now whatever whatever you
want to do man and we'll bring you up on
your show yeah I've offered it many
times before and I will offer it again
send us a message we will bring you on
the show right now sure absolutely I
would love to hear your crazy thought
here's the thing a lot of people might
start believing that fake Gabe is a bit
but it is not a bit I promise you out
there this is what's your address why
would I tell you my address just give me
your email and I'll send you a [ __ ]
invite dude right you got you go to my
Facebook page you're right there and
anyways just [ __ ] DMS your your your
email and we'll send you a link buddy
what's wrong with you why don't you
believe us I would definitely put you on
camera I would want the world to see
that's that's the craziest part about
this whole thing Gabe is like a lot of
my a lot of my haters a lot of them
they're like oh we don't like you
because you you have you have this
microphone and you have this show thing
yeah a lot of them are really mad that
we have a a pretty good following on
Facebook I mean we get thousands of
views a day on Facebook thousands tens
of thousands of views on YouTube they're
really pissed off about this stuff and
they all hide behind Anonymous accounts
thinking also might have just given a
detail to the chat he said he's not too
far from Los Angeles
oh is that right oh it might even it it
might even seem like he's from a town
that starts with an O
oh really oh
like oh oh like it starts with an O
starts with an O but I don't know I mean
this could be a different fake game that
is easily searchable on Google I
promised the audience fake game is not a
bit he is
he is as fake as he is real like he's
he's actually in the chat saying that
[ __ ] I don't know if he actually
believes it or not but this guy says the
[ __ ] did you know that they changed they
change from Maga to magaga did you hear
this
they actually put gag it's it's uh
I you know they you know the bit from
um
no from the well mugabaga is what I just
added to it but what I'm saying is on
um on Sesame Street
or no sorry sorry the Muppets where
they're like the I forget what the what
the creature's name is but
um he does the song was like
I think I remember
but it's magaga now yeah I know I know
but I'm saying I can't I can't wait to
change my verbage from Maga because
everyone says I say it wrong I say Maga
well I I understand I know I know people
that say Maga as well I say Mago I know
why you say why maybe because I say
salsa
make America yeah maga maga but I say
Maga a lot of people say magic wouldn't
say America you say it like Don Jr so
that's the thing is that oh okay
I'm at least consistent with manga
itself yeah what is does Donald Trump
say manga or Manga
uh I don't know hmm it's interesting
well and I wonder if well I don't know
maybe he said it but I've only ever
officially make new hats with magaga on
it yeah I mean I know there's gonna be
people selling magaga's shirts oh yeah
I'm just gonna gag on this [ __ ]
presidential run right now that's crazy
that they went from Maga I mean that was
worse that was bad enough but to Brand
themselves like you can see them right
out in the open like oh okay but now
it's gonna be my gag uh he's in the gag
is in the [ __ ] hey hey can we call
you right now
can we call you right now on the online
on the on the
on the show
are you are you talking to him
yeah I'm talking a fake game I'm asking
if we can call him on the show right now
he ain't gonna do it
I don't know no he won't nope he says
Nope oh my god
oh man listen the reason why this guy
won't show on camera is because he's
scared for people to know who he is and
the reason why is because he's a little
nutty he's nuttier than a squirrel turd
hey look fake Gabe I love having you
here I hope you continue to come here
and type in crazy [ __ ] into the chat you
actually create like I don't know
there's a possibility you create at
least you know at least 15 20 30 minutes
a week of content because you're crazy
some type into the [ __ ] thing it's
crazy [ __ ]
listen Gabe there's a lot of video to
get to and I want to show you a couple
videos from the Trump speech I thought
we would be playing a lot of it I'm only
going to play One Clip of him talking
though possibly
but I want to show you what happened in
the back of the room as he's just
rambling on you've probably seen these
clips but I also want to show you these
reactions from from magaga
magaga I want to show you the reactions
from mcgaga this morning of this low
energy announcement so everyone sit
tight we're gonna surf the Tweety tweets
and trendy Trends as long as Twitter 1.0
is still around I know 2.0 is the um the
dictator
um over there Twitter is going to pump
out 2.0 so as long as 1.0 is right now
we'll we'll surf the Tweet tweets and
training Trends so start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Michaels podcast we have reached the
part of the show where we round up all
the Tweety tweets and trendy Trends on
the [ __ ] list around it before we start
game
I want to say we have the best audience
in the world and we run on their support
again there's a tip jar at Tony Michaels
dot live Tony Michael's not live you can
give a one-time tip or you can set it up
to do it monthly everything is
appreciated and also if you want to get
something if you want to give you can go
over to
store.vtonymichaels.com that
store.thetonymichaels.com and get you a
Rhonda santis can go [ __ ] himself he can
definitely definitely go [ __ ] himself
Gabe here's why
um this morning he's a little he's a
little pissed off it seems that Trump
announced he's a little perturbed if
he'd say that
um here is um a short little clip of
some journalists asking him about the
the the Cheeto dust q and honors
announcement last night at Mar-A-Lago so
let's uh let's take a listen here
so if you couldn't hear the question
that the reporter was asking he said do
you feel like there's a civil war
Brewing inside the Republican Party
here's here's the Florida fascist
response now look I think we we just we
just finished this election okay people
just need to chill out a little bit on
some of this stuff I mean seriously we
just ran an election
he obviously is a little upset Gabe yeah
I mean I mean maybe maybe a lot upset
not just a little and well that I I
think it's it's directed towards Trump
more than anything he's telling him hey
calm down Karen calm down
well also I just sent you a clip that
kind of goes against it earlier look we
all know that the The Profit when it
comes to political elections is the Mike
Lindell my pillow man Mike Lindell now
last night he was at this announcement
right yeah he was and well him and him
and a bunch of other Bandit criminals
yeah exactly exactly announcement uh but
he made a prediction yeah or he said
what was going to happen this morning
and based on the video that we just
watched it seems to not
it seems like this this clip you send me
is not going to have any crazy built
inside of it since it's Mike Lindell I'm
sure it's completely sane
and Tethered to reality let's take a
listen here here we are live at
Mar-A-Lago look at all the fake news
from around the world I just had a ball
with them uh talking to almost all of
them uh they asked me about uh Rhonda
Santos running against Donald Trump and
I said after tonight Ronald just endorse
him in the morning you got to believe
that why would you want to waste all
that time energy money and everything
else so very exciting here and uh it
seems like that's what Rhonda Santos did
in that last clip it seems like he
endorsed him I mean maybe it was like a
kind of like a cryptic type message but
it really did seem like Ron DeSantis was
in the camp of trump in that Lance clip
yeah I mean look I it's it would very
much seem that Ron DeSantis was I think
the position because we have to keep in
mind Rhonda Santos just won his
re-election okay he's not going to right
there I don't even think they've
certified it yet like a fish I mean no
no not yeah yeah I mean like he is The
Unofficial winner but like Anthony is
the governor elect right and even though
he is the governor he's the governor
right right he's crazy like he doesn't
get sworn in until next year and so what
is he gonna announce in February like oh
Valentine's Day comes around he's like
now this is a real lover's quarrel
DeSantis versus Trump no he's not going
to do that a month after he gets re like
through the uh his inauguration what's
gonna happen is he's either not gonna
run or he's going to hold off and
probably have to hold off for another
six to eight months or nine months I
mean it probably wouldn't even announce
anything until the end of next year
to actually say something because then
he's got you know a 10-month period or
so I I was telling the audience
um earlier that Trump running is not to
fend off indictments Trump is going to
be indicted the the Trump running is
Trump trying to fend off a trial because
if you look at the timeline and the
layout of when he would be indicted and
how he could kick the can down the road
for the trial and then the trial would
come sometime during the primaries he
could really legitimately say at that
point I'm a candidate and I can't go to
trial so I mean possibly that might be a
legal strategy that he's employing
because and by legal I mean just
stalling that's all he's doing he's
stalling the inevitable
um
but I think you're right in that Rhonda
santis is going to wait long enough to
really really really make sure he enters
the race When Donald Trump is at his
lowest point and that probably comes
when he's having a lot of trouble with
more criminal trials piling on top of
him next year yeah meaning he's probably
going to be indicted on this documents
case first because it's pretty cut and
dry it seems like especially the
evidence that Donald Trump made the doj
release it's really kind of [ __ ]
weird I mean you'd also think that if
you were under investigation in the
State of Florida yeah in in DC Georgia
New York right possibly Arizona and
Michigan at this point yeah because of
those that state elector scheme and
you've got a rape defamation case uh
that you that's on the docket as well go
away for this game you would think any
sane logical person who was dealing with
that type of legal [ __ ] that you
would say a I don't need to put myself
out in the Limelight or the spotlight
right now because this shit's already
crazy enough I want to kind of just like
Dodge this [ __ ] as it is and then maybe
later I'll go forward with it but in
some crazy idea Trump thinks that
running is going to avoid any League
which it doesn't just everyone who's out
there if you run for president you could
be in be in jail and still run for
president right you cannot just evade or
avoid the law you know Law and Order
right running for president it doesn't
like get out of jail free card kind of
situation and again he's not he's not
going and I think he's come to terms
with this that he's not going to avoid
indictment what he's trying to do is
avoid a trial that's what he's trying to
do just like Manus and cother should
avoid using the Trump hair filter is
this a trump air filter what the [ __ ] is
this I thought it when I saw that in the
in the thumbnail at the bottom I
honestly thought that uh it was like a
like a yellow gel like a fur not like
gel put in hair but like uh for lights
you'll have like a gel filter yeah
that's and that's what it looks like it
is a light but it looks like he's trying
to I mean honestly that when I was
watching this video I wasn't even really
listening to it much I was like what the
f why is he trying to make the Trump
hair filter Max Headroom what is that is
it some kind of reference to something I
don't know it's a reference to a
character it's it's pretty spot on here
yeah grab the picture of it watch watch
a little bit of um uh Wheels here talk
about how he's went to Mar-A-Lago and
how he's gonna be a trump sick event
still which is not surprising but listen
listen to Old Madison cawthorne here you
know that he's another [ __ ] loser in
the Republican party yeah I will follow
this man until the day I die you know
barring some terrible information but
foreign
terrible information what possible more
terrible information than you try to
overthrow the government you tried to
you tried to usurp the people's voice
you you are a known [ __ ] grabber out of
your own mouth what [ __ ] posture
you're a fraud you're a tax cheat what
possible thing could turn you off and
let's keep in mind that also Madison
cawthorne you know uh but Mohawk cousin
humping
uh sexual assaulter
uh College liar
uh I it's not quite uh
uh Stolen Valor but he did lie about
getting accepted into the Naval Academy
after the car accident that he tried to
rewrite the story on but his friend
corrected the story because he was
Madison cawthorne was trying to sue his
friend in the insurance company because
there they were uh driving their their
truck or the car and they were switching
seats in the middle of it because they
didn't want to go to the restroom and
stuff
if anyone wants to look up the backstory
in Madison Hawthorne and why he is the
way he is no no one no one wants to look
that up I mean but this this is this is
Madison Oh I thought this was Madison oh
no this is yeah this is Madison cauthor
this is a this is a virtual view of
Madison Hawthorne oh my God I'm not
gonna play the rest that quit [ __ ]
um the uh the picture is enough for me
um there's some more clips that I want
to show you but the one that I want to
show you from the actual speech and I
think this is the only one that I'm
going to show the speech unless we come
up with something that we need some
context here
but this one here well okay I'm gonna
show two I'm gonna do it I'm gonna show
two because this one is really short and
it sums up the entire Trump presidency
his 2016 run his 2020 run and now it's
gonna be his campaign slogan here listen
to this
and I'm a victim I will tell you I'm a
victim think of it uh there it is there
it is there's his campaign slogan
literally he said that [ __ ] last night
he said that [ __ ] into a microphone
normally when you're trying to I don't
know like
propagandize people you don't really say
that certain thing that you want them to
believe you're trying to like get them
to you know get them to believe it
without actually saying it that you're
the victim and you're just a little
[ __ ] and you're a [ __ ] you're a punk
ass [ __ ]
um but here is here's a moment he said a
lot of Q Anon stuff and what I mean by
that is like just kind of uh you know
not really outright but just like dog
whistles right
well that yeah that too that too but but
no he said a lot of stuff that was like
um the storm is coming [ __ ] like that
you know just using that [ __ ] now
they didn't play the music that I know
of like the the Q Anon where we go on
where we go all the the yeah
I was assuming that they would at one
point right like especially if he came
in but turn the turn the track on and
yeah whatever that music is um here's
the one that I want to play though of
the speech this is my favorite part of
the entire speech literally you can't
write this any better than the way he
says it here listen
very good thing actually because look at
what's happening today
my opponents made me out to be a
warmonger
and just a terrible person I would
immediately go into war they're so mean
they said during the 2016 campaign that
if he becomes president there will never
be a war within weeks and we will have
wars like you've never seen before it
will happen immediately and yet
I've gone decades decades without a war
the first president to do it for that
long a period
okay so there's a lot to unpack here
dude really does believe that he was
President for not just decade which he
was not but decades and decades like so
more than two decades even it seems that
he thinks he was President I mean it
felt like it felt like a thousand years
to be quite out you know what this is
the same type of thing that fake Gabe
deals with you know like I said he feels
like he's in a 1980s Macho Man uh yes
Montage of working out and oh yeah
shooting guns First Amendment and being
a Pedro exactly I'm just saying and then
you realize that you're like oh wait
that never happened you aren't those
things
um
like Donald Trump and I was the
president for decades I prevented out of
your mind
he thought he was like you know what it
feels like I've been president for
decades yeah it was a [ __ ] long four
years of xenophobia hatred and God damn
just destructive just just destruction
it's amazing we survived it's amazing we
survived that [ __ ]
A lot of people don't ruin the panda
well you know he brought up he brought
up a lot of things last night where he
was like
he brought up uh the most votes that any
sitting president has had which is true
right which is true because more people
voted right but also he lost because the
majority of Americans said yeah and I
think he even said I think he even said
during that moment he's like let's do it
again like
ouch man I mean I'm [ __ ] lose not
only did you lose twice in the popular
vote but you did set a record he's the
only sitting president to be impeached
twice right in one term
well the other the other crazy thing
that he keeps saying which is it just it
boggles my mind that he thinks this is
popular he keeps saying that he's gonna
give the death penalty to people who
sell drugs like what he pushed out like
dude
even yeah right even in Missouri where
they elected someone who is
anti-marijuana
uh Eric Schmidt as the United States
Senator we voted in recreational
marijuana people are not anti-drugs in
this country anymore that's not a thing
that we have gone past the situation
where we are we are for the drug war
let alone giving people the death
penalty yep and death penalty in general
is something that we really should
consider as a society not doing but yeah
but when you're just saying as someone
who's a drug dealer should it's really
crazy stuff okay here's again like he
pushed it he pushed it several he pushed
it I think on November 7th in Ohio he
pushed at another Ohio rally when he was
promoting he's done it several times
this is part of Majewski the guy who
almost bigly yeah yeah literally Trump
supported him surely Majewski won
hmm nope okay good yeah good well um
maybe they all walked out on Majewski
like they walked down on Trump last
night this you can see this is the the
the
um the loser room down at margolango is
that what they call this the loser
Ballroom is that I think so you know I
thought about something I saw I saw a
bunch of empty chairs when they were
setting up you know yeah and I was like
oh yeah someone took a picture of it and
posted yeah yeah and they're like wait
and I was like I wonder if they used
this same
like do they just borrow the same seats
from Tiffany's wedding from a couple
days prior did they do it did they do
Tiffany's wedding at Mar-A-Lago yeah
yeah yeah oh okay see I didn't know when
I shared that when I shared that photo
the Jazz Dixie cup versus her thing
I didn't know I didn't know where it I
didn't know where it was held I had no
idea I guess I should have assumed it
was held at Mar-A-Lago because again
it's always held in Mar-A-Lago I mean
every wedding for the Trump children has
been held at Marlon right do you think
do you think he used fake Gabe in the
donors money for Tiffany's wedding
do you think he used the I mean no
because I think that he still charged
Tiffany's like uh fiance now husbands
parents
was like yeah come have it at my
Mar-A-Lago Hotel yeah yeah and I'll give
it to you for a discount and the I added
20 probably easily Donald Trump is the
type of shitty parent that charges his
own son or daughter getting married at
his
Golf Course Country Resorts home
treasonous Palace whatever the [ __ ] you
want to call it I guarantee Donald Trump
is the type of shitty parent that would
say ah you know what how can I make an
easy Buck I know I'll ask or I'll say
you should have it at Mar-A-Lago and
then I'll say I'll give it to you at a
discount and then he up charges on
whoever the other like the The spouse's
parents and family is to be like all
right how about you how about you chip
in but isn't which is really the whole
Vision but isn't the tradition yes the
woman the tradition is that but are you
are you seriously telling me that you
think that Trump is going to go forward
with a tradition like the Father of the
Bride is the one who pays for the
wedding I mean well I mean if anything
he was going to use grifted money for it
that's what I'm saying No this yeah I I
see that this is a scene again
um this is from the back of the room you
can see um the Cheeto dust mobster oh
excuse me cueing on her formerly the
Cheeto dust monster the Cheeto does q
anoner's up here at the front in front
of his thousand American flags this is a
little obnoxious isn't it and it's a
little obnoxious these are a lot of
trees to or did he hug all of those I
was gonna say I was gonna say trees to
[ __ ] but they're Flags to [ __ ] he's a
yeah you know he's not I mean we know
like he he makes out with flags he's
done it on stage before but the thing is
he's stuck he's got him all the way up
how many does he have back there I don't
know it's a lot one two three four five
six seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 15
16 17 18 19 20. so there's at least 20
behind him right and it looks to be six
on the side on his left and six on the
right so that's 32 total and it looks
like they recycled the make America
great again signs right because he
didn't buy a new one of those he's just
like well don't we have those um hidden
the top secret documents yeah exactly
somewhere so we just pull those out of
the pool house where the documents were
found and we'll hang those up like you
didn't show them up yeah just throw them
up and you know we don't need to come up
with a new does somebody like dust them
off
you know trying to trying to clean them
off but here here's the back of the room
you can see even in this still shot a
lot of people are kind of frustrated
like this guy down here he's frustrated
some of these other people are trying to
like it just it looks like a like a a
crowd of people to not know where
they're going yeah but watch what watch
what happens in the scuffle here is you
hear Grandpa yapping in the background
[Music]
help is on the way Joe Biden is
abolished America's borders we are going
to restore and secure America orders
just like we have
we built the wall
and now we will add to it now we built
the wall now we wanna I wanna I wanna
point something out here this is the one
part if you look right here at this guy
you see this guy right here that's
walking in the crown you see him there
watch his gesture as he comes to the
crowd he's talking to someone across the
way watch we built the wall and now we
will add to it he's doing I don't know
if he's saying cut him off like the guy
talking I think what he's saying is
they're not letting us out because
apparently what happened and I'll go to
it
yeah all right so I know I think I know
what you're gonna say so apparently what
happened was a few people were trying to
leave and it looked like the whole crowd
was gonna leave because they got tired
of listening to Grandpa Yammer on about
the same [ __ ] that he hammers he does
this same speech like when there is
another wedding at Mar-A-Lago and he
comes out and he crashes their wedding
he says he's like lock down the doors
I'm giving a speech right these people I
don't know but they paid me money to
have this wedding here I'm going to tell
you about how the 20 20 election was
stolen right so all these people are
like headed for the door and so that
there's not a huge Exodus of people to
empty the chairs and [ __ ] in this room
while he's still talking they lock the
doors and do not let them out
um but if you go let's go back one more
time and watch this guy he does the
throat cut thing like nope and I think
what he's saying is we can't get out of
the room see him there
they're not letting us out yeah yeah
yeah he's pointing out the door which is
totally on brand if you remember when
Trump has held rallies inside a venue
outside you can get away but however all
right well let me clarify this when we
settled fences remember Walter mattress
and told us that right right right so
they started setting up fence points
exactly so inside they wouldn't let you
leave which is a pretty sure that's
illegal and also fire hazard and then
outside uh was fenced in but not only
that it was when he was having these
rallies outside like even the ones that
he was having in 20 2020 leading up to
the election he left people outside in
the [ __ ] cold with no way to get back
and the coordination of buses like he
hired those those companies to
coordinate
uh the transportation to and from and
then when someone like in Nebraska when
they left yeah yeah
and cold right and so what's they're
left uh out in the cold trying to figure
out how to get back the buses aren't
coming Trump gets on in his car goes to
Air Force One boom out of there
and everyone else is [ __ ] left us
people are like Patriots like they've
done or Mommy over there come pick them
up fake Gabe says here uh Trump never
mentioned 2020. I never said you did
well he did I listened to it you dumb
[ __ ] he talked about the
pandemic and lied about the pandemic but
what he's what he's saying is he never
talked about the 2020 electrons break
that's not what I said oh my God you're
such a bonehead okay so go back and go
back in the tape and listen to what I
said yeah cut it cut it and post it on
Facebook somewhere um here's here's
Jonathan Carl talking about the same
moment that we were watching from a
different angle listen to what he says
about the the exiting of the room
probably low energy I actually saw
people trying to leave
um and people leaving early even before
he was done he's still speaking now uh
and then they I think perhaps a little
concerned that that the hallway the hall
would empty out too much they actually
started preventing people from leaving
so now they're no longer allowing people
to leave
so like live reporting as grandpa is
still yeah I mean he's literally
becoming an escape room like you have to
Now find the clues to like to get to the
person that has the key to open the door
to let you out and so you've got to
decipher like a [ __ ] Dakota ring from
the Christmas uh from Christmas story of
like how to figure out the key words of
like you know inflation crime
uh uh this transphobic comments uh
everything that he says you have to
figure out how to like break it down and
be like ah I know exactly where to go
now we get out so it's like so it's like
almost like a loser escape room type
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah that might not
be a bad game to play you could set up
an escape room house and play the Trump
loser Escape game
um Sarah Matthews would like to play
that game do you remember Sarah Matthews
you know who Sarah Matthews is she's the
she's the former deputy press secretary
she's the one that oh she worked under
does she work under Kaylee mcenany that
is true yes and she's the one that went
to the January 6 select committee and
said yeah he's a [ __ ] oh that's right
yes that is right there yeah okay
um Cassie Hutchison and Sarah Matthews
were the ones that kind of buried the
whole narrative because that was the day
it was her and there was another guy
right and they were like we
we had to get out this is crazy right
right so here is her um giving her
reaction on CNN to the um Trump
announcement let's listen Sarah you seem
to have a pretty similar reaction last
night to Jeb Bush who of course was in
turn kind of mocking Trump saying what a
low energy speech by the Donald time for
new leaders what'd you think
yeah I mean it was just that it was low
energy uninspiring I mean during my time
working for president Trump I've watched
him give hundreds of speeches over the
two years that I worked for him and that
was by far one of the most boring I mean
he himself seemed boring while giving
this speech and you could tell he was
trying really hard to stay on script but
then he started to get bored and started
to ad-lib and it just turned into a
rambling mess in my opinion Sarah the
National Review this morning I think
says uh reflects what a lot of former
allies of the president Republicans are
thinking and saying that the headline is
just no I think we can show it and the
first line is to paraphrase Voltaire
after he attended an orgy once was an
experiment twice would be perverse
I know I didn't say it they wrote it I
just repeated it but do you do you think
do you he's a joke he's a [ __ ] joke
he has been for years he's been the joke
for years and they never liked him they
always [ __ ] hated him and and it's
absolutely crazy that he would decide to
run but he did and he's going to and
it's gonna not run you got to remember
that even after the midterms a [ __ ]
lackluster embarrassed embarrassing
devastating performance of his
candidates that he endures I mean really
the only ones that were that that made
it were uh Lombardo and JD Vance but
everyone else was rejected outright
especially when it came to Secretary of
States the people that would be in
charge of the elections you know so you
also had Governors and other states that
were just [ __ ] that lost that were
endorsed by Trump which is hilarious so
Trump comes in
or rather comes out of the midterms with
this like devastating embarrassing loss
because all these candidates lost and
now he's thinking hey I gotta keep the
attention on me I'm in attention like
that's what he's attention [ __ ] is what
he is he loves the attention he cannot
have people not talk about him and this
is something where he's like I can stay
in I can stay in the news people will
talk about me if I run for president
again even though leading up people are
like don't don't do that don't do that
I'm glad you said uh he stays in the
news because the New York Post had a
very interesting take do you know who
owns the New York Post I'm I'm trying to
look it up here um is it I think last
name starts with an M oh meredy murdered
oh Rupert Murdoch is that yeah okay yeah
yeah obviously and we've done that bit
before sorry um but here's the thing is
the New York Post put him on page you
can see your page 26 put this story and
put it in the column right
um and it's a post-stack report if you
look here it's not even it's probably
like Murdoch wrote it and he's like I'm
gonna use my voice in here so here the
headline here in this um staff reporting
box is been there done that in other
words get the [ __ ] out of here the
highlights say a Florida retire a
Florida diary made a special
announcement at Mar-A-Lago his Resort
and classified documents Library ooh
[ __ ]
um goes on to say his cholesterol levels
are unknown but his favorite food is a
charred steak with ketchup and then they
quote stable genius so
at the end they recognized that he was
the 45th president of the United States
um unfortunately I I this is this is
literally the story that they ran with
in the New York Post murder I have to
assume that there is a staff room of
writers and Murdoch is like all right
guys I need puns
I need insults I need everything we can
and they literally have probably a board
with like note cards pinned up like it's
a goddamn uh monologue in a in a writers
are are putting it together for like a
late night show and they've got all the
jokes lined up and they've got here are
the puns that we can hear the names that
we can call them using or hear the
phrases we can use Don with right uh
here's all the insults ketchup charred
steak
um little hands hissy fit uh tantrum man
baby orange all of these things that
they can that they have on the list and
they just throw them together and
sometimes it could be like a Mad Lib
style where they're like insert noun
went here and then insert adjective you
know so like they're making a game out
of they're having fun
I mean let's also keep in mind too that
Robert Rupert Murdoch is not abandoning
Trump he says publicly that he's
abandoning Trump but like the money
is in the trumpty Dumpty okay he knows
that's where it is and last night some
people were like I made this some I made
a a tweet that was a screenshot of the
actual broadcast from yeah because Fox
News carried the majority of they
actually yeah half of it or so when he
just kept ramming on they cut away but
what my my tweet said was like Rupert
Murdoch was like I'm not gonna you know
I'm not gonna back his running in 2024
and then also Rupert Murdoch like let's
broadcast his announcement and then I
said if you something along the lines of
like if you really thought Rupert
Murdoch was going to abandon him like
that's the joke right well Rupert
Murdoch's gonna do what's good for Fox
News
can get Trump supporters to watch Fox
News he's gonna do that and also if
people back Trump he's going to have to
he's going to be the one that gives some
attention right
um Roderick you point out a great thing
with the trumpy Dumpty because that that
New York Post
um after the midterm the trumpet Dumpty
had a great fall was was a great one by
Rupert now speaking of Trump's 2024
campaign there's a new campaign video
out on Donald J
trump2024.com apparently the good liars
apparently the good liars
um got this URL Donald J trump2024.com
and there's a new political
head out for let's let's take a listen
six years ago Donald Trump started a
movement we will make America great
again they're bringing drugs they're
bringing crime they're rapists he
brought this country together you also
had people that were
very fine people on both sides he
brought class and respect back to
Washington uh I don't know what I said
at all I don't remember losing is never
easy not for me CNN projects Joseph R
Biden Jr is elected the 46th president
of the United States we will never
concede
and we're going to the Capitol
[Music]
in 2024 he's gonna do it again and lose
the popular vote for the third
consecutive time
in 2024 the loser loses again if I lose
to him I don't know what I'm gonna do I
will never speak to you again Trump 2024
the loser loses again
whatever you do don't spread that
campaign message around it'll help
Donald Trump I am sure the good liars
thank you for your
for your um always good I mean that's
you know he said all those things
those are not he did say those things
and he's still saying a lot of them yeah
and he's still I will say this though he
didn't really push the big lie last
night which was interesting I think
that's what maybe fake Gabe was talking
about is he didn't push the big line and
I think that the positioning here is is
that he believes the only reason why
America voted against some of his
candidates is because of the big lie but
which is crazy to to have him have that
like 20 well but here's the realization
though is that how would you mount a
campaign for 2024 when you when you
continue to say they stole it from me
there was no way they're gonna let me be
president I mean how would you go out
and be
support me even though they're gonna
steal it and there's no way they're
gonna let me well also him running for
president acknowledges the fact that he
lost yeah well and that's the Q a Niners
were pissed off did you see some of the
screenshots from no I saw the stuff on
Reddit which basically where people were
throwing him under the bus I did see
some videos from Christian Walker last
night where he was like
which I kind of agreed with because I
was like these are some insane takes but
he called it's a weird it's a weird
situation when you're like hey Christian
you yeah you're spot on it's like people
were calling or well he was calling out
people that had these like dumb takes
that said Trump should run in 2024 so we
lead up for uh Ron DeSantis in 2028 and
2032. and the thing that I agree with
Krishna and he's like when has a
republican ever had three consecutive
terms right and gone through like we
couldn't even get a [ __ ] Red Wave in
the right terms what makes you think
that we'll get this guy and then another
one and then another one after that like
you'll be lucky enough to get the next
one which is Trump which again Christian
is another one of these fair weather
Republicans right who were on the
[ __ ] coattails of trump and love
Trump and everything Trump said was
truth and the election was stolen and uh
Mike pension do his role and do his job
or I'll still get really mad like he
literally made a video about that right
in line at a Starbucks
and then you were in the back seat
weren't you yeah I was in the back seat
at that time yeah and then what happens
is uh Trump uh just [ __ ] up and loses
again because let's keep in mind like
2018 wasn't great for candidates and
2020 wasn't better and then 2022 was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] show of this Red Wave just
becoming like a red like Trickle
and he acknowledges it and he but also
you see a lot of the Republicans that
are like oh well Ron DeSantis is the
future Ron DeSantis is the future and
it's like well dude like four weeks ago
you were really pushing Trump you're
pushing Trump and all of the Trump
candidates I'm excited that Ron DeSantis
is is the future because this morning
his little response at that press
conference was only tells me that he
will not survive a national race no
[ __ ] wank in that guy's he's too much
of a baby he's too weak he's too fragile
he's too thin-skinned he will not be
able to survive and the reason why is
because he can't pile on top of someone
like Trump can
um speaking of piling on top of people
here is um this is going to be a clip of
Liz Cheney talking about trumpism now
Gabe there's a universe here where the
Democrats lose the house but Liz Cheney
could still be the speaker of the house
it's kind of far-fetched but you know I
still like to play with fantasy why not
why we're you know it's a q Anon World
we're just living in it we might if if I
were I would totally throw a wrench in
you know Kevin McCarthy's though keep in
mind Kevin McCarthy didn't get all of
those he needed because he needs a
certain amount he needs 218 and he got
180 something yeah he did 170 something
and Matt gas is still firmly against him
um so the fighting continues and I'm
enjoying it right it's it's fantastic
but listen to this um little excerpt of
Liz Cheney they played in on uh uh
deadline White House yesterday I respond
to this John Carl let me show you what
Liz Cheney who was
um once in his own party now she's a bit
of a king maker in the other party
um in these midterms let me show you
what she had to say about tonight
this is certainly not the rollout I'm
sure Donald Trump wanted for his
announcement tonight
um but you know it's also not the first
time he's been totally detached from
reality
um I I think though uh it's also really
important for people to to look at
what's happening and what he's doing not
just through a political lens but
um through the basic facts of his total
um
lack of Fitness for office he's unstable
the January 6th committee has laid out
very clearly his direct and personal
involvement in every aspect of the plan
to overturn the last election
um he's you know someone who knowing
that the mob was armed sent them to
march on the capitol to try to stop the
count of electoral votes and then while
that that Bloody battle was underway at
the Capitol uh despite everyone around
him pleading with him to tell the mob to
stop and go home he wouldn't he wouldn't
do it he sat and watched it on
television so there's no no question
that that he's unfit for office
um and uh
and I feel confident that he will never
be president again
John Carl
political indictment for Cheney it
sounds like what could become the text
of a criminal referral is that a foot
by the January 6th Select Committee
so there it is um Liz Cheney's reaction
Gabe what do you make of uh Liz Cheney
trying to burn down Donald Trump's house
here oh [ __ ] it let's do it uh if she
needs if she needs to any kerosene you
know
I I'm happy to happy to supply some I
mean like look Liz Cheney she made it
very clear during the like she knew
obviously that she lost Wyoming and then
when it came to the January 6 committee
uh requesting you know subpoenaing like
giving Donald Trump a subpoena to to
give testimony
um was another clear-cut that she is
coming after Trump and she will burn
trumpism down to make sure that her
party you know the Republican party is
is somewhat salvaged like there's gonna
be a lot of [ __ ] debris that's left
over from this fire but she's like look
I can I can make do with the scraps and
we can rebuild from there
but we need to make sure that we have
completely like cut this out you know
assuming it's a cancer we need to we
need to cut that [ __ ] out of there and
remove it so that this party can survive
um as opposed to being you know
overtaken by this like parasite host and
that's what she's trying to do right now
so what do you make of the um the talk
that Democrats are like maybe we'll just
get behind a Liz Cheney speaker and
maybe we can recruit I don't know a
handful of Republicans to vote for Liz
Cheney's speaker because a speaker of
the house only needs
218 members to vote for them right yeah
that it doesn't matter which members
vote for that speaker because they are
the speaker of the house now generally
speaking when you have a party that's
not fractured
um
or there's one that's manga and one
that's magaga at this point
um you know they're sort of on different
gagging Pages
um normally you would have a majority of
more than one or two that would vote for
a person in their party right to get
them to be Speaker of the House the
problem that Kevin McCarthy and the
Republicans really have here are their
own magagas yeah Matt gatz uh Andy Biggs
some of these others that are full on
gagging the magaga stuff yeah and that
Trump is going to come back as king and
it's there he's going to Pardon them and
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] so they do not
want Kevin McCarthy to be the speaker
now he convinced Kevin McCarthy convince
Marjorie Taylor green but there is this
this talk out there
and I I think it's a beautiful
um you know kind of delivery that the
Universe could give us if the Democrats
for whatever reason could just get in a
room and go you know what we don't
really don't like Linda Cheney and the
last thing we want to do is vote for Liz
Cheney for speaker of the house because
I don't want that on my record but
but
for the sake of the storyline and the
sake of the drama that's going to go on
in this country in the next two years
maybe just maybe it's not a bad idea for
us to band together rather they're 216
or 217 they only need a couple
Republicans that would agree to vote for
Liz Cheney because she can be even
though she's not a member of Congress
she can be the Speaker of the House yeah
it would it would definitely be
something that uh I mean well here's the
thing it's like
Matt Gates had also been pushing the
idea that president or former president
Trump uh would be the speaker of the
house which was you know I guess obvious
he could totally do that if he wanted
right uh but tried to push that idea and
I look at that I'm like at least that's
uh at one point I was like that could
have been possible right at one point
Trump running for 2024 for president was
a possibility but after the midterms
this is not something that he'll be able
to do he is such a [ __ ] loser that
nobody wants to put their [ __ ] in his
basket right and and the only people are
the people that you talk about which is
like you got the Paul gosar Martin
Taylor green Lauren bobert Matt Gates
all these [ __ ] Andy Biggs all these
people the Gaggers the Gaggers
Gaggers the Gaggers we got a new name
for them folks the Gaggers the Gaggers
because you think of it and you're like
oh God
24.
the Gaggers so that's what they are but
I will say that the idea of Liz Cheney
being Speaker of the House uh I like it
as a I like it as an idea right I think
it's funny however there is a part of me
that does see how that could go south
in the next couple years right uh well
yeah don't don't get me wrong I'm not
saying it's like ideal I'm just saying
for like the storyline I mean we're
we're in pretend World anyways right now
Robin Robin points out that Liz Cheney
lost she did lose but there is nothing
that keeps Liz Cheney from being the
speaker of the house even though she's
not a member of Congress anyone anyone
can be the speaker of the house this the
the requirement is that the majority 218
vote for that person to be the speaker I
do want to say though in in reality if
if the Republicans had a more of a
majority here if they would have had a
red wave I actually believe that Liz
Cheney would be more of an effective
Speaker of the House for conservatives
right for their agenda than what Kevin
McCarthy could ever dream of Ken
McCarthy is a [ __ ] cuck he's an idiot
now Liz Cheney is the the thing that I
don't like a lot about Liz Cheney is she
is super [ __ ] smart and she is
vindictive and she does not give a [ __ ]
about you she will [ __ ] come after
you she will she will hit you and bury
you with that same shovel she hit you
with like this person will not let down
listen when a Cheney
shoots at a republican they do not miss
okay that is uh that is a family
tradition that the Jamies have they do
not miss when they shoot at a republican
it's genetic they definitely know how to
shoot and oops I didn't mean that what
happened so there is definitely
um a universe where Liz Cheney could be
president now rather that's the timeline
we're in because again we're at we're at
the intersection of WrestleMania in real
life still here and and the only proof I
have of that is that a three-time
[ __ ] popular vote loser just
announced that he's going to be
president before the [ __ ] votes are
counted for the midterm that they lost
big time in they [ __ ] lost and the
reason why they lost folks I know they
keep they're going to keep going well we
won the house and we won Florida but you
weren't going to lose Florida and you
should have won more in the house where
they really lost Gabe and we'll talk
about it over and over and over again
Pennsylvania Michigan
Arizona and Wisconsin those three
[ __ ] States they could not get
election deniers they could not get q a
Niners in either Secretary of State or
the governorships which basically gives
us a backstop on Democracy that is our
real true backstop there for the 2020
War race
so so they didn't win because that's why
they wanted Arizona so bad oh yeah
totally I mean they wanted these swing
state these these these states that were
Always In Contention during the 2020
election that because here's the thing
if they won those States the election
denialism I'm here I'll say this
election denialism isn't dead they're
going to continue to push that we'll see
it happen in 2024 I'm almost certain of
it because you have people who are
running in 2022 and 2020 they were
bitching and moaning about that
it's not dead they're still going to
push the idea because it does have some
ground with some constituents
and they're going to it could have been
way worse if those people the governors
and Secretary of States actually won who
were in who were um
uh candidates endorsed by trump it would
have been much worse and 2024 would have
been at stake because those people would
have been the ones in power who would
have signed off to say Yep this state
voted this way and that is the candidate
they voted for
so uh thankfully yes there was a
backstop on democracy and people had
some sanity to be like oh well that's
[ __ ] crazy I don't want that and
obviously the GOP the Republican Party
didn't do themselves a favor we talked
about it with Rachel uh bitikoffer the
other day which is like they were
laughing at the fact that you know Paul
Pelosi was attacked in his home they
were laughing at the fact that all these
other things were like they they take
pleasure in other people's pain
especially when it's to own the Lambs
and all this [ __ ] when really
they're just owning their own voter base
it really is pathetic um Matt I don't
know what you're talking about here but
uh Matt Bryant on Facebook says if the
Democratic party wants to win in 2024
they wouldn't need to focus on money and
politics and ending Citizens United
Court corporate personhood it was almost
every it's almost what every voter wants
yeah I get it but here's the thing Matt
that is a shitty message the Democrats
have tried that message in the past
they've tried it and tried it and tried
it trust me when I tell you this man
keep listening here come here every
single weekday two hours noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter or
twitch and you're on Facebook come here
and listen here because the narrative
that we had here the entire time is The
Narrative that won we we had the
narrative that won there were a lot of
people out there like tyt and David
packman with his defeatives and [ __ ]
that is that's usually where the
Democrats go they try to scare you into
thinking you're going to lose something
and that's going to actually activate
your vote it doesn't it doesn't people
go vote against [ __ ] and let me tell you
something Trump in 2024 and even if he
loses primaries which he's going to do
he's not going to win these primaries
he'll stay in the race because he won't
he won't go away he's he's like a bad
[ __ ] girlfriend he just won't go the
[ __ ] away just a stalker he's a [ __ ]
stalker on American democracy is what he
is or a bad boyfriend I don't mean to
kind of you know bad boyfriend guys is
it just a toxic relationship really is
what Trump is right he's a stalker on
American democracy and let me tell you
something as long as he's stalking as
long as he's stalking American democracy
and we point and go hey look this guy is
stalking American democracy and and the
people who are on our opposite side are
encouraging him to stalk us and then
stalk American democracy that's the
narrative he's going to win you say
citizens united no one gives a [ __ ] no
one gives two shits that's like this
narrative that somehow Joe Biden's gonna
have some kind of contender in the
primary shut the [ __ ] up with that
nonsense Joe Biden is gonna be the
nominee of the democratic party get over
it that is just what it's is going to
happen there's no need for us to fight
over this and there's no need for us to
fight over what narrative works against
magaga there is a clear narrative that
works to defeat magaga and we need to
continue it we need to lean into it and
it's pro-democracy everything that we
must do from now until the 2024 race is
to push The Narrative of democracy and
lean into it and I know the citizens
united and you could say this and that
all that's part of democracy yeah but
you're getting in the [ __ ] weeds you
don't need to get into the weeds here
that's why they [ __ ] didn't have a
red Wave It's because Democrats did not
get into the weeds of a policy or or a
line item in a bill so Matt I get what
you're saying and I agree with you I
agree with you citizens united as [ __ ]
and it is rot our country but that is
not the messaging my friend that is not
the messaging that is not the narrative
um speaking of narratives let's listen
to see what the Trump family you know
who this is this is Laura Trump
did you know that she's actually married
to Eric
I know and they have children and I feel
sorry for the kids only I mean like if
you look at the photos like you know or
the videos you know you got a kid
screaming and she's sipping on that
Trump wine like you know cool mom and
then she's also telling uh her
her son during also hurricane weather it
was raining where she was in Florida and
being like Oh we learned a lesson today
you know it's like
your child is crying in the video and
you're laughing about this your child is
crying in another video and you're
laughing about this the the Trump family
are some of the most vile
disgusting and incompetent parents I
have ever met and I wouldn't be
surprised if people I wonder where they
get it from I wonder where they get it
from it's almost it's one of those I
mean like shitty people raise shitty
people and it's the unfortunate you know
uh
environment that they're raised in and
you know crazy [ __ ] Donald Trump
Donald Trump uh his father did it to him
he did it to Don Jr and Eric and you
know not so much Ivanka Trump but it's
just you know shitty people raise shitty
people and it's because of the situation
they're in and part of me kind of feels
sorry for the kids you know but I was
like man you know you're all kind of
[ __ ] so I don't feel sorry at the
same time ah she's an ass head already I
got a couple Clips to show you here
um from Fox Business let's listen to
this first one here
I'm sure you're very supportive of your
father
those of us on the outside looking at it
it didn't seem as he got the old magic
Varney is now on the outside isn't that
funny now he's on the outside he was
inside Trump's ass for [ __ ] years
well he's he he kind of there right he
came out and he was like oh my God I can
breathe and then as soon as he came out
it was like get back in there and then
he was like no I'm getting out obviously
because everyone at the Fox News
Corporation has been told by Rupert
Murdoch to probably not he's up on the
whole the whole magaga thing right well
let's listen to what uh the mcgaga queen
says here you know what I mean you know
what I mean oh well I highly disagree
with that look for Donald Trump from the
very beginning from the first day he
came down the escalator in 2015 in Trump
Tower it's never been about elected
officials politicians people uh you know
in the swamp in DC it's been about the
American people and if you look around
the room last night you had people from
all different walks of life the energy
there at Mar-A-Lago was absolutely
incredible it really did to me feel like
the 2015-2016 campaign
oh my God oh my God it's it's fantastic
isn't it this is great I can't tell you
how how how much better this could get
for Democrats and demise when she's
saying this type of [ __ ] here's another
one here's another one and and here's
what they're gonna do they're gonna go
here's what they're gonna go with
they're gonna go with the strategy of
The Narrative of gas prices in 2024. I'm
not [ __ ] you listen this I've got 30
seconds but here's what I'm hearing
Trump will go into the primaries and
money will win the debates he'll
Steamroller over his opponents but when
it comes to the election 2024 he can't
win he won't win what do you say
oh highly disagree with that I think if
there's ever been a time that people
know we need to change course it's right
now they know how good it was with Trump
in office and even those that might not
like his tweets and personality I think
would be much happier to pay lower gas
prices be able to afford their groceries
and have a better trajectory for their
lives true true literally she says right
now like we didn't just have a [ __ ]
election where they repudiated the
[ __ ] nonsense it's it's
Insanity these people literally I don't
and Wendy Rogers said it yester we
played the clip yesterday where she
talked about being in an echo chamber I
I can't even describe what kind of
security this Echo chamber it's probably
the security that they had in the
[ __ ] loser room at Mar-A-Lago when
they were trying to keep the magagas in
um because they just are not letting
people out of this Echo chamber she
literally says right now in this country
right now like you know in this moment
where we just voted the entire country
voted in a midterm that the gas prices
are the problem that's not what people
if that is the truth then they trust Joe
Biden and they trust the Democrats more
in more places
then then they do Republicans on gas
prices and groceries it's it is
oh my God they are so out of touch with
the voter base look at 2022 as a mock
election for the 2024 General president
exactly what it is too that's exactly
look at 2022 as a mock election to
understand if you test the because this
is what they did
they pushed a bunch of narrative and
messaging and they tested it right they
they say ah what works here okay
let's erase the divisiveness the
xenophobia the hatred the transphobia
all this stuff
let's push election denialism right and
all these candidates that Trump backed
double down on it and they're like yeah
this is the way forward and again I'm
sure that other candidates in the future
in 2024 will continue this same type of
narrative even though they know it's a
losing one
and in 2022
the overwhelming well not overwhelming
but a majority of Voters said no right
that [ __ ] ain't gonna fly anymore we
don't like that because we've realized
now obviously that there are more of us
than there are of them there are more of
us that support democracy and actually
believe in what this country was founded
on not what the Republican party and
trumpism is pushing forward and so we
said nope not today fascist and whether
you actually support Trump or don't
support Trump or whatever it is like
there are people in there just the same
way that people voted against
Trump or for Biden because they hated
Trump or they didn't want that they're
like look the Lesser two evils here I'm
going to vote for Biden I don't love
Biden but I'm going to vote for him and
there are those people and in the same
way for 2022 these people are like I
don't want anyone that's associated with
this guy that has lost caused the party
to lose seats in the last couple
elections
we just can't do that anymore I don't
want him there I want someone else so
they voted against him they voted
against those candidates they voted
against everything that Trump stood for
so 2022 was a mock election and it gives
you a pretty clear idea like pretty
clear picture of how 2024 would go by
saying no on the ballot for those
candidates in 2022. why I'm gonna go to
a clip here but I want to pull up Matt's
comment here he's got a big comment here
um and it's talking more about Citizens
United and he says he loves the show he
loves a message here and I'm glad you're
watching Matt and the only reason why I
want to have this conversation right now
is because we are we are we are we are
months and months away from the 2024
election even becoming a thing the only
reason why Donald Trump is doing this is
because he wants the conversation to
turn to him not turn to the Santas
that's why he's doing this and the
reason and the other reason why is
because he's trying to fend off this
trial not the indictments because he's
going to need it as a political Ploy now
here's what I want to tell you man and I
want to tell the audience this too that
I understand I understand that campaign
Finance is and super important in this
country to get our democracy back I
understand that but what we cannot do is
let them take our narrative and win
elections because if we don't win
elections we cannot change citizens
united it will not happen so by talking
about citizens united it's not a winning
message it's not a winning narrative and
I understand why you want to talk about
it I understand what the actual goal is
I get it I'm on the same page but here's
the thing Matt the only way that we're
going to change citizens united is to
make sure that Republicans are not in
charge of our federal government the
house the senate or the presidency we
have to make sure we secure democracy so
we cannot we cannot focus on citizens
united we have to focus on how we can
win the same way in Pennsylvania
John fetterman ran a campaign against Dr
Oz he didn't focus on what Dr Oz was or
wasn't going to do in when he became
Senate veteran beat him where he could
beat him which is to say this guy isn't
from Pennsylvania like literally that
was the entire campaign this guy isn't
from [ __ ] Pennsylvania he's a [ __ ]
carpet backer and he's a fraud he's a
phony so much a phony he's running in
Pennsylvania a state where he doesn't
live that was the entire campaign and
fetterman won on that fetterman won on
that message and that's and that's what
we have to do we have to get behind a
winning narrative so we can get
grabs of power to make sure that we can
change certain policies we can codify
Roe v Wade there I know people were mad
the other day when Joe Biden said that
there's no way he's going to kind of
fight Roe we wait there's not he's not
going to codify it with the makeup at
the house right now he's just not going
to be able to do it he I know he would
like to he would sign that [ __ ]
in a heartbeat if that son of a [ __ ]
got on his desk but Joe Biden's
realistic chicken that way and he knows
how government works he knows how the
system works now he's excited that there
is that backstop on Democracy like we
were talking about but we to codify Roe
v Wade we have to lean into this the
next two years stronger than we did in
the last two years and stronger than we
did in 2020. my
my
optimism here Matt is this
is that there is a generation that is
coming but coming up into our country
that is very interested in being engaged
in civil debate and Civics and they are
very interested in knowing how democracy
works and how how to protect democracy
and that's gen Z and that voting block
is going to get bigger and bigger and
bigger and as they engage with each
other they're going to get more and more
engaged especially in a presidential
type race where there's going to be the
primaries in the general election this
is going to be very important that is
why we have to keep the narrative to
democracy that's why we have to this is
going to be a choice in 2024 just like
it was a choice two weeks ago you either
are on the side of autocracy or
democracy they're not going to change
just because they Reba re-brand to
magaga doesn't mean that they don't want
to tear down our democracy so we cannot
lose sight of the narrative audience we
cannot lose sight of what we have to do
to win and what we have to do to win is
have a national message that every
campaign can ride on and ride on those
coattails and I'm telling you that's why
I was so excited about Donald Trump
announcing because it's such a big [ __ ]
up this is the most horrible thing that
the Republican Party could do right now
they would never dream of wanting Donald
Trump to run in this moment that is not
what they want and that's why we should
encourage it anything that hurts them
because they are the party of autocracy
they are literally the party of
autocracy that citizens united thing
that you're talking about that's them
that's what they want there's only a a
big Coalition of people who are against
citizens united in the pro-democracy
party and the reason why is because
citizens united is not democracy it's
not
so we must we must we must make sure
that our narrative is in a way that we
win so I I I my Matt keep coming back
keep listening every single weekday two
full hours noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific or catch us on replays on
YouTube or Facebook
um follow us everywhere it's going to be
super important for the next few years
that we keep this narrative going and
and a winning narrative and a winning
message and we will keep the Strategic
outrage here you mentioned Dr Rachel
bittickoff or Gabe Sanchez back in
February we had Rachel on for the first
time and she coined the phrase strategic
outrage yeah and me and you were like
she's [ __ ] right I believe that you
believed it and we're like that's the
message we're going with that's what
we're gonna do from now until the
election and we're gonna do an after the
election now that that strategic outrage
is what wins elections folks that is
what wins they they deploy that strategy
every single election Republicans that's
why they were like bathrooms genitalians
CRT is the strategic outrage with crazy
stupid lies but we can do it with the
truth we can do it with the truth but
also all the things that they push when
they were like oh so outraged and they
you know they want to complain about gas
prices those prices have gone down they
want to talk about inflation we're
seeing inflation you know go down these
are these are things that the Republican
party has no foresight to Future proof
right they have no idea when they make a
complaint to say these are the things
that Democrats are doing poorly these
are the ways that in which uh the
country is going down right they say
those
because well they say them at the time
and those moments are left flash in the
pan they're not a real problem they're
just like oh this is an issue we have to
deal with right now and as President
Biden he goes okay great let's deal with
those things let's actually let's work
with the FED we'll work uh releasing the
reserves over here and we'll do this
over there and we'll make sure to work
on domestic policy and foreign policy
over here like working to improve those
things and actually address them to make
this country better but Republicans want
to just complain complain complain never
actually offer a solution when a
solution is presented by the Democratic
party they say nope and they vote no on
it and you see that over and over and
over again infrastructure chips uh uh
price gouging all of the the pack act
all of these things that you saw the
Republicans push down and say no to
should be enough evidence to show you
that Republicans don't care but also
should show you that they don't have the
foresight to think about what position
that puts them in later on when those
things turn coarse and actually become
better or show that the social programs
work or so or show that the Democrats
actually do have policies and programs
that help Americans as opposed to
Republicans who say that'll never work
we just gotta cut taxes and it'll
trickle down and all this [ __ ] that
never ever helps anyone
well um Alan says here get Rachel back
on we're probably gonna have her next
week
um she said she'd come back on uh she's
obviously she's been busy you know yeah
right leading up to the midterms and
we're um so we're hoping to have her on
next week once they settle the house so
she can give her comments on that and
going forward Rachel is a master at
messaging
um and we should continue that narrative
um again we all leaned into this thing
and uh we we were not gonna have
defeatism here uh Matt again he says I
appreciate the feedback I think gen z uh
knows all about citizens united they do
they're very educated and I mean I think
it was Nevada I think I read today
Nevada they looked at the numbers and it
was because of gen Z right it was
because of the younger voters that
pushed those races over the line for
Democrats and he says he says I will be
here and I will keep talking about money
and politics absolutely man keep doing
it keep doing it and I'm not I'm not
saying I'm not going to talk about it
but what you have to understand about
narrative and National messaging is it
has to be broad it cannot be focused
because when Democrats get too focused
that's when they're like well that's not
oh minimum wage needs to be 18 not 19.
well it needs to be 21 not 19. when you
have a national narrative you want to
have a national narrative where everyone
can get underneath that umbrella
everyone can get underneath that's how
you build coalitions even when the
coalitions do not agree that's why Trump
was so successful at getting all these
white nationalist groups under one
umbrella because he's like well we're
just going to be a white nationalist
Nation that's what we're going to do and
they're all like yeah see that they
weren't he wasn't prescribing to any one
particular brand of white nationalism he
wasn't he he made it Broad in 2016.
that's why he was able to attract all
these crazy Kooks and that's why he
continues to have them so when you have
National narratives and you have
National messaging to win in democracy
you have to make it broad so keep
watching keep coming back keep
commenting uh we'll keep having this
conversation as they go on I got one
last clip I want to show you and Gabe
because I said yesterday or was it
yesterday or day before it was the day
before when Rachel bidikoffer was on I
said my prediction is that if the
Republicans win the house and they
actually appoint some of these crazy
[ __ ] Cuban honors as committee chairs
that I would bet that the the word
laptop is going to be entered into the
official record at least 2 000 times in
the first 60 days of the um house the
new House of Representatives
here's just more proof of that I guess
you could say all of the things that the
Committees will look at in terms of
their jurisdiction to go out there and
conduct oversight over Hunter Biden or
over the Afghanistan withdraw a host of
the different things those things will
be run through the speaker's office so
that's why it really matters to the
American people who the speaker of the
house actually is the the
oversight of Hunter Biden what the
hunter Biden is not in the federal
government how many times do these
people have to be shown that Hunter
Biden is not the president he does not
work at the White House he's not the
first son
he's not the first child
that's not a thing it was a thing in the
last Administration where that the
Cheeto does q and honor would allow his
children to come in and give him advice
on the government frankly he would he
gave his son-in-law enough power that he
probably fleeced and got and gazillions
of dollars from Saudis yeah in deals
that he made in the Middle East this is
a little this is a little tell here that
their main goal
and and again Matt I'm telling you I'm
telling you their National message here
because they only have one chamber they
only have one place they won well
Florida but this answers is going to use
that to mount his presidential campaign
not a national Narrative of Hunter
Biden's laptop the Republican party is
gonna go balls deep into Hunter Biden's
laptop in Afghanistan yep those are the
two things this they're telling you out
loud what the [ __ ] they're gonna be
talking about and what their National
narratives laptops and a war that went
on for 20 years in America is glad that
we ended and not only that but it was a
war that we learned and the withdrawal
from that war we learned you know
keeping in mind that we just passed
Veterans Day on November 11th right we
just passed a two-year Mark in which
Trump signed an expedited order
and his his military advisor like uh we
should not do that that is not a good
idea well when when was it ever that he
signed something like oh that's a really
good idea no yeah never never did he
sign something where someone's like
that's that's pretty good but we learned
during the ninth day of the January 6
committee they revealed
that Trump on November 11th Veterans Day
is a real [ __ ] you to our our military
service members is to withdraw from
Afghanistan and Somalia
just a rush job get them out of there
and now you've got them talk about how
whoever the speaker of the house is
going to run a committee on oversight
and tunes like the withdrawal of
Afghanistan yeah it's pretty obvious you
look at the past guy who just announced
he's gonna [ __ ] run for president
again that guy was the one who was
warned not to do that not to pull out
because it was going to be a mess they
knew it was going to be a mess before
they did it and then Trump knew he lost
the election and said not my problem
it's for the next guy which is Biden so
if they want to look into it fine the
January 6 committee already did a bunch
of the investigation and already
revealed through different testimonies
of depositions that it was Trump that he
was the one that caused it well I didn't
had his hands timed he had to go there
but this is the Republican demo they
always self-destruct they did it they I
mean Matt Walsh the the guy running
around the country wanting to marry
young girls and talking about children's
genitalia constantly is why wondering
why did that message not why did that
message not resonate with people it
really is bone-ended stuff they
self-destruct they continue to do this
nonsense Hunter mind's a laptop the
Afghan war CRT and transgender people
are not a very good mess winning message
yeah election denialism not a very good
message and they're going to keep doing
it though because they're Republicans
that's what Republicans do and you know
what we do Gabe we come here every
single weekday two full hours noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and Twitter so don't forget if
you're on the YouTube page right now we
we're at almost 12 000 subscribers this
morning I'm not sure I'm not sure where
we're at now I can't confirm or deny but
I'm sure we're getting very close
so if you're on YouTube right now and
you're not subscribed to our Channel hit
that and do us a favor hit the Subscribe
button right now and click the Bell
notifications because you don't want to
miss a single episode and also download
every single episode on Apple's Spotify
Google your favorite directory while
you're there subscribing on your
favorite directory make sure to leave us
a great review follow us on Twitter why
Twitter still exists uh at Tony Mike 16
16
follows away oh my gosh 15 subscribers
so hit it right now get us to 12 000
subscribers if you can go follow us on
Facebook too at the Tony Michaels and
you can follow us on Twitch as well some
people like the chat over there some
people hate it but I mean you know
twitch is Twitch it's a free app you can
download it we don't pay anything we
need to download the app but go go
follow us on Twitch if you can if you
like um that over there we run on your
support remember visit tonymichaels dot
live Tony Michaels dot live if you want
to give some money in the tip jar you
can give a one-time tip or you can set
it up monthly we appreciate anything you
can give not just the tips but also the
likes the shares the retweets when
you're coming and engaging Matt it's a I
hope we can continue these conversations
yeah fake game
don't go anywhere continue to come here
so we can I'm gonna try to call you
again to schedule you to come on I've
invited you you say that you're not too
far from me in La you uh I've tried
calling you seriously yeah right he
seems like he's trying to but um also
and fake Gabe go grab you now that I
know you're in California this shirt
might fit you really well go to store
not the Tony michaels.com that's
store.donymichaels.com this shirt is
going to become more and more relevant
as we go along here Ron DeSantis can go
[ __ ] himself grab this great design in
the merch store that
store.thetonymichaels.com and tell
Rhonda santis that he can go [ __ ]
himself
everyone same time same place tomorrow
Surf's Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
foreign
[Music]